This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We were almost done working on this week's show when news broke Thursday evening. News that required an on-air warning before our colleagues could even discuss it. And Oval Office conversation turns vulgar. And I want to acknowledge what I'm about to say could offend some people.
这里是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。正当我们快要完成本周节目的制作时，周四晚上爆出了一条新闻。这条新闻甚至需要我们在同事讨论之前先发出播出警告。椭圆形办公室的谈话变得粗俗。我想承认我接下来要说的话可能会冒犯一些人。
He asked why the United States would admit people from African nations, which he called shit hole countries. Trump then told lawmakers he would rather see more immigrants from Norway. The vote are coming out. I'm not a racist. I am the least racist person you have ever figured out.
他问美国为什么要接纳来自非洲国家的人，他称这些国家为粪坑国家。随后特朗普对议员们表示，他更希望能看到来自挪威的更多移民。选票出来了。我不是种族主义者。我是你们所了解的最不具种族主义的人。
In light of President Trump's comments, as well as ongoing debate over the program known as deferred action for childhood arrivals or DACA, we thought we'd switch gears and bring you this conversation from October 2016. As a journalist, I think this conversation is timely. As an immigrant myself, I think it's essential. Our airwaves are filled with debates about migrants, refugees, and undocumented immigrants. Who should be in the United States?
鉴于特朗普总统的言论，以及围绕被称为“童年抵美者暂缓遣返”或DACA计划的持续辩论，我们决定转换一下思路，为您带来这段2016年10月的对话。作为一名记者，我认为这场对话非常及时。作为一名移民，我认为这至关重要。我们的广播节目中充斥着关于移民、难民和无证移民的辩论。谁应该留在美国？
Who shouldn't? And who should decide? It's an issue that seems to get to the core of who we are, who we want to be, and where we're headed as a nation. Today we're going to take a fresh look at the issue by exploring what history can teach us about the patterns and paradoxes of immigration in a nation of immigrants? My guest today is Maria Christina Garcia. She's a historian and professor of American studies at Cornell University. Maria Cristina, welcome to Hidden Brain.
谁不应该？谁来决定？这个问题似乎触及了我们是谁、我们想成为谁，以及作为一个国家我们正走向何方的核心。今天，我们将通过探讨历史能教给我们关于移民国家中移民的模式和悖论的启示，来对这个问题进行全新的审视。我今天的嘉宾是玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜·加西亚。她是康奈尔大学的历史学家和美国研究教授。玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜，欢迎来到《隐秘的大脑》。
Thank you. So we call ourselves a nation of immigrants, and that's more than a saying, it's more than even a fact, it's a foundational story of the United States. And I want to start with this idea, many of us take genuine pride in being a country whose most famous symbol is the Statue of Liberty.
谢谢。所以我们称自己为移民国家，这不仅是一句俗语，甚至不仅是一个事实，它是美国的建国故事。我想从这个想法开始，我们许多人为自己是一个最著名的象征是自由女神像的国家而感到真正的自豪。
That's correct. Immigrants and refugees are central to the American National Mythology to the stories that we tell about ourselves as a people. We honor this history with museums and historical markers. We commercialize it with celebrations like St. Patrick's Day and Mausincol de Mayo. But despite the centrality of immigrants and immigration to the American story, many of us have been wary of immigrants and we see this all throughout history. We have attention there, we have a contradiction. One has only to read a Benjamin Franklin, for example, to get a sense of these contradictions. In the 1750s, for example, Franklin called the German residents of Pennsylvania stupid. He complained about their inability to learn English, and he warned his readers that they
没错。移民和难民是美国国家神话的核心，是我们作为一个人群讲述自己的故事的核心。我们用博物馆和历史标志来纪念这段历史。我们用圣帕特里克节和五月五日节这样的庆祝活动将其商业化。但是，尽管移民和移民在美国故事中占据核心地位，我们许多人一直对移民保持警惕，我们在整个历史中都能看到这一点。我们存在那种紧张关系，存在一种矛盾。人们只需阅读本杰明·富兰克林的文章，就能感受到这些矛盾。例如，在18世纪50年代，富兰克林称宾夕法尼亚州的德国居民为蠢货。他抱怨他们学不会英语，并警告读者说他们
would soon overrun, that Germans would soon overrun the American continent. And yet, it's also important to know that Benjamin Franklin published one of the first German language newspapers in the colonies. So there was that contradiction there, right? So fast forward also to the early national period. Immigration was welcome because it was important to nation building.
很快就会占领，德国人很快就会占领美洲大陆。然而，同样重要的是要知道，本杰明·富兰克林出版了殖民地最早的德语报纸之一。所以那里存在着那种矛盾，对吧？快进到国家早期阶段。移民受到欢迎，因为它对国家建设很重要。
We needed immigrants. The new nation needed immigrants to work in the mills and the factories to work in the mines, to harvest the crops, to build the infrastructure of American towns and cities. In many communities you didn't even need to be a citizen in order to vote. And yet, you know, a couple of decades later by the 1840s and 1850s, we see the emergence of the Know Nothing Party immensely hostile to German and Irish Catholic immigrants, demanding
我们需要移民。这个新国家需要移民在磨坊和工厂工作，在矿山工作，收割庄稼，建设美国城镇的基础设施。在许多社区，你甚至不需要成为公民就可以投票。然而，你知道的，几十年后的1840年代和1850年代，我们看到了“无知党”的崛起，该党对德国和爱尔兰天主教移民极为敌视，要求
federal restrictions on immigration, and trying to prevent immigrants from voting and holding public office. There are so many other examples I could give you. You mentioned the Statue of Liberty during the 1870s and 1880s, as the Statue of Liberty is going up in New York Harbor to celebrate the end of slavery. Americans are demanding at this time that the Chinese be barred from immigrating to the United States and in Congress complies in 1882 with the Chinese Exclusion Act. So we see these tensions and these contradictions all throughout American history.
对移民实行联邦限制，并试图阻止移民投票和担任公职。我还可以举出很多其他的例子。你提到了自由女神像，在1870年代和1880年代，正当自由女神像在纽约港竖起以庆祝废除奴隶制时，美国人当时却在要求禁止中国移民入境，国会在1882年通过了《排华法案》。因此，我们在整个美国历史中都能看到这些紧张关系和矛盾。
I understand that you yourself came to the United States as a refugee and your own family, your own history of for surviving in the United States and being seen by others, and then your own family's history in terms of how you see other people coming in, or how your family sees other people coming in, reflects this broader pattern, this tension, or this paradox in how we think about immigration. Yes, you're right. My family immigrated in the 1960s. I was just a toddler. We immigrated from Cuba. We were privileged compared to other immigrants.
据我所知，你自己就是作为难民来到美国的，你自己的家庭、你们在美生存以及被他人看待的历史，以及你的家人在看待其他人到来时的历史，或者你的家人如何看待其他人到来，反映了这种更广泛的模式、这种紧张关系，或者我们在思考移民问题时的悖论。是的，你说得对。我的家人在20世纪60年代移民。我当时还是个幼儿。我们从古巴移民。与其他移民相比，我们享有特权。
We were privileged because we were refugees arriving during the Cold War from a communist country. And so the proverbial red carpet was rolled out for us. But just two decades later, we see another migration from Cuba during the 1980, Murray Al-Bot left. And by the 1980s, those Cubans who had arrived earlier and were more established and had managed to move up the economic ladder, and were feeling much more secure in their position, began to feel very nervous about the new arrivals who were coming in from Cuba in 1980.
我们享有特权是因为我们是冷战期间从共产主义国家抵达的难民。因此，他们为我们铺上了象征性的红毯。但仅仅二十年后，我们在1980年看到了来自古巴的另一场移民潮，即马列尔偷渡事件。到了20世纪80年代，那些较早到达、根基更稳固、已经在经济阶梯上向上爬并对自己的地位感到更有安全感的古巴人，开始对1980年从古巴涌入的新移民感到非常紧张。
They wondered if these new Cubans who had grown up in a communist regime could truly understand democratic institutions, whether they could understand capitalism. And so these older Cubans, more established Cubans, wondered if the new arrivals would undermine everything that they had accomplished in South Florida and in other communities where they had settled. We see this with every immigrant group. When you look at American history, again, history can teach us a lot. For example, in the 19th century, some of the most vitriolic voices of the anti-Chinese
他们怀疑这些在共产主义政权下长大的新古巴人是否能真正理解民主制度，是否能理解资本主义。因此，这些老古巴人、更有根基的古巴人在担忧，新来者是否会破坏他们在南佛罗里达州以及他们定居的其他社区所取得的一切成就。我们在每个移民群体身上都能看到这一点。当你审视美国历史时，历史再次能教给我们很多东西。例如，在19世纪，反华运动中最尖酸刻薄的一些声音
movement were Irish immigrants and their children, who themselves had been much maligned. And now, in turn, they were directing a lot of that hostility towards newer arrivals this time from China. German Jews who had arrived in the early 19th century were also highly suspicious and worried about the Eastern European Jews who migrated at the end of the 19th century because they too feared that their status in society would be undermined by the newer arrivals. So I guess it's a very human response for those who are more established to worry about what the newer arrivals might do to undermine their hard work. So this is such a fascinating idea that people come to the United States and within a couple of decades their point of view shifts from the point of view of people who say, we really
来自于爱尔兰移民及其子女，他们自己曾饱受恶评。现在，他们反过来将许多敌意指向了这次来自中国的新来者。19世纪初到达的德国犹太人也对19世纪末期迁徙的东欧犹太人高度怀疑和担忧，因为他们同样担心自己在社会中的地位会被新来者破坏。所以我想，对于那些根基更稳固的人来说，担心新来者可能会如何破坏他们的辛勤工作，这是一种非常人类的反应。因此，这是一个如此迷人的想法：人们来到美国，在几十年内，他们的观点就从那些说“我们真的很”
want to make it in the United States to being really worried about whether the people coming after them are going to be able to make it in the United States. And we sort of see this pattern writ large in all manner of ways, you know, in the current debates that we have about immigration. I've heard people say, you know, in the current debates that we have about immigration. I've heard people say, you know, people whose families have been here for many generations. They say that, you know, when their ancestors came to America, they wanted to become Americans to leave old ways behind. And some of these people worry that more recent immigrants are less interested in assimilation.
想在美国闯出一片天的人，转变为非常担心后面来的人是否能够在美国闯出一片天。我们在当前的移民辩论中，以各种方式或多或少地看到了这种模式的大规模重现。我听人说过，你知道的，在当前的移民辩论中。我听人说过，你知道的，那些家族已经在这里繁衍了好几代的人。他们说，你知道的，当他们的祖先来到美国时，他们希望成为美国人，把旧习俗抛在脑后。其中一些人担心，最近的移民对同化的兴趣不如从前。
But from what I'm hearing you say, that might not actually be grounded in historical reality in terms of how immigration patterns have unfolded over the years. You're so right. Many Americans today believe that the new immigrants are too culturally different, that they're coming here to take American jobs or mousse off of welfare, that they have the run politics, that they don't want to learn English, that they don't want to assimilate, that their national security threats. But these attitudes, they're not new.
但从你的话中我听出，就移民模式多年来的演变而言，这可能并非真正植根于历史现实。你说的太对了。今天的许多美国人认为，新移民在文化上差异太大，他们来这里是为了抢走美国的工作岗位或靠福利生活，他们会操控政治，他们不想学英语，他们不想融入，他们是对国家安全的威胁。但这些态度并不是新鲜事。
Americans have been saying this about every immigrant group throughout American history. According to American immigration mythology, those who came, say, in the 19th century or in the early 20th century were the ideal immigrants. They learned English quickly, they wanted to be Americans, but the study of history doesn't bear that up. When you study history, it challenges those assumptions that we have about the older immigrants versus the new immigrants.
在整个美国历史中，美国人对每一个移民群体都这样说过。根据美国移民神话，那些在19世纪或20世纪初到来的人是理想的移民。他们学英语快，他们想成为美国人，但历史研究并不支持这一点。当你研究历史时，它挑战了我们对老移民与新移民的那些假设。
So for example, let me give you a couple of examples. From the study of history, we now know that not everyone who came to the United States stayed. The two groups that had the lowest return rates were the 19th century Irish and Eastern European or Russian Jews. Every other immigrant group had return rates between 20 and 80%. We also know from the study of history that most immigrants who came to the United States did not immigrate to become American. In many cases, in most cases, immigrants came to replicate the best of the old country
举几个例子。通过历史研究，我们现在知道，并非所有来到美国的人都留下来了。回流率最低的两个群体是19世纪的爱尔兰人和东欧或俄罗斯犹太人。其他所有移民群体的回流率都在20%到80%之间。我们从历史研究中还了解到，大多数来到美国的移民并非为了成为美国人而移民。在许多情况下，在大多数情况下，移民来到这里是为了复制故土最好的部分
in more favorable circumstances in the new. As I said earlier, in many communities, you didn't even need to be a citizen in order to vote. We also know from the study of history that in the 19th century immigrants didn't learn English quickly. From the very beginning, this was a multilingual society. And it oftentimes took several generations for English to become the dominant language on Main Street. Our founding documents were all published in German to accommodate the German speaking populations.
并在新地方更优越的环境下生活。正如我刚才所说，在许多社区，你甚至不需要成为公民就可以投票。我们从历史研究中也得知，在19世纪，移民并没有很快学会英语。从一开始，这就是一个多语言社会。英语往往需要几代人的时间才能成为主街上的主导语言。我们的建国文件全部用德语出版，以照顾讲德语的人群。
For most of the 19th century instruction in public schools across the country, from Pennsylvania to Texas to Wisconsin, populations. For most of the 19th century instruction in public schools across the country, from Pennsylvania to Texas to Wisconsin, occurred entirely in languages other than English or bilingual. And this practice was not abolished until the first decades of the 20th century. So our preoccupation today in the early 21st century with requiring linguistic and cultural conformity, that's really a recent phenomena. From the study of history, we also know that immigrants
在整个19世纪，全国各地公立学校的教学，从宾夕法尼亚到德克萨斯再到威斯康星，人群。在整个19世纪，全国各地公立学校的教学，从宾夕法尼亚到德克萨斯再到威斯康星，完全使用英语以外的语言或实行双语教学。直到20世纪的前几十年，这种做法才被废除。因此，我们今天在21世纪初对要求语言和文化一致性的全神贯注，实际上是一个最近才出现的现象。从历史研究中，我们还知道移民
didn't think of themselves as legal or illegal. They just didn't think in those terms. During much of our history, people moved across our borders with ease. If your ship docked outside of New York City, chances were you weren't even interviewed. Congress passed the first immigration laws to control the movement of people beginning
并不认为自己是合法还是非法。他们根本不从这些方面去思考。在我们的大部分历史中，人们可以轻松地跨越我们的边境。如果你的船停靠在纽约市外，你甚至很可能都不会被接受采访。国会从
in the 1870s, but the mechanisms to enforce those laws were pretty few until the 20th century. Indeed, the first border patrol consisted of only a couple dozen men on horseback. So when someone says to me, my ancestor is immigrated legally. Why can't they? My first question is, when did your ancestors immigrate? Because if they immigrated in the 19th century or in the early 20th century, they simply didn't use that vocabulary. They didn't think in those terms. So clearly, much of the language around immigration has changed over time. But there are also ideas that have remained relatively constant. When we come back, I'll ask Maria Cristina about the long and tangled relationship between immigration and national security.
19世纪70年代开始通过第一批移民法来控制人员流动，但在20世纪之前，执行这些法律的机制相当少。事实上，第一支边防巡逻队仅由几十名骑马的人组成。因此，当有人对我说，我的祖先是合法移民。为什么他们不能？我的第一个问题是，你的祖先是什么时候移民的？因为如果他们在19世纪或20世纪初移民，他们根本不使用那种词汇。他们不这样思考。很显然，围绕移民的许多语言随时间发生了变化。但也有一些观点相对保持不变。当我们回来时，我将询问玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜关于移民与国家安全之间长期且纠葛的关系。
Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Our debates over immigration are often framed in the context of national security, fears of terrorism. To many of us, this feels relatively new. Part of the 9-11 world we've lived in over the past 15 years. But Maria Cristina Garcia says that if we look at history, we start to see that our modern concerns are a new version of a story that's been told over and over again. Americans have been concerned about national security
请继续收听。这里是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。我们对移民的辩论往往是在国家安全和恐怖主义恐惧的背景下进行的。对我们许多人来说，这感觉相对较新。这是我们过去15年来所经历的“9·11”世界的一部分。但玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜·加西亚表示，如果我们审视历史，就会开始发现我们现代的担忧不过是一段被一遍又一遍讲述的故事的新版本。美国人一直都在关注国家安全
since the 19th century. One has only to look at the political cartoons of Thomas Nast, for example, to see how concerned Americans were about Irish Catholics, for example. Thomas Nast produced these political cartoons warning Americans about all these Catholics who were coming to the United States who were under the influence of the Vatican who didn't understand democratic principles and would undermine democratic institutions.
自19世纪以来。人们只需看看托马斯·纳asts的政治漫画，例如，就能看出美国人对例如爱尔兰天主教徒是多么担忧。托马斯·纳asts制作了这些政治漫画，警告美国人注意所有这些来到美国的天主教徒，他们受梵蒂冈的影响，不懂得民主原则，会破坏民主制度。
And so that's an early example of Americans concerned about national security. In the late 19th century, you see Americans expressing great concern about all the southern and Eastern Europeans who are coming in, who are anarchists and Bolsheviks and socialists who don't understand, again, don't understand American democracy, will undermine American principles, American democratic institutions. And this concern is strong enough that it forces Congress to pass a series of court alas, a barring immigration from southern and eastern Europe. We see concerns about the Chinese and other Asian groups. So we see that concern about national security throughout American history. Americans may not have used
所以这是美国人关心国家安全的一个早期例子。在19世纪后期，你会发现美国人对所有涌入的南欧人和东欧人表现出极大的关切，他们是无政府主义者、布尔什维克和社会主义者，他们同样不理解、不懂得美国民主，会破坏美国原则、美国民主机构。这种担忧是如此强烈，以至于它迫使国会通过了一系列法案，禁止来自南欧和东欧的移民。我们看到对中国人和亚裔其他群体的担忧。因此，纵观美国历史，我们都能看到对国家安全的担忧。美国人可能没有使用
the exact term national security in the 19th century, but you see those concerns all throughout the history. I want to spend a little bit of time talking about the World War II period and the experience of Japanese Americans in the United States, because it seems like that's certainly a moment where concerns about security and concerns about loyalty to the United States intersected with how we were thinking about an immigrant group. It's true during periods of national emergency, immigrants become likely scapegoats. We saw this during World War II with the internment of Japanese immigrants, but also their
19世纪的“国家安全”这个确切术语，但你在整个历史中都能看到这些担忧。我想花一点时间谈谈二战时期以及美籍日本人在美国的经历，因为这似乎确实是一个时刻，对安全的担忧和对美国忠诚的担忧与我们如何看待一个移民群体交织在一起。确实，在国家紧急状态时期，移民很容易成为替罪羊。我们在二战期间看到了这一点，当时日本移民被拘禁，而且他们的
American-born children, who, even though there was no evidence that Japanese or their children were conspiring against the US government or against American society. The government decided to err on the side of caution and round it up this population and put them in internment camps. It was one of the most shameful periods in American history. Those who were interned and their children felt the consequences of that executive decision for many, many decades afterwards. And so that's just one example.
在美国出生的孩子，尽管没有证据表明日本人或他们的孩子在密谋反对美国政府或美国社会。政府决定采取谨慎态度，将这群人围捕并关进拘禁营。这是美国历史上最耻辱的时期之一。那些被拘禁的人及其子女在之后的几十年里都感受到了那个行政决定的后果。这只是一个例子。
But also during World War II, there were many opportunities that we lost to accommodate people fleeing Europe. And we lost that opportunity because we feared, again, we were concerned with national security. We feared that among the refugees, among the immigrants, would be spies and saboteurs that would undermine the United States. But those fears prevented us from accommodating many, many people who were fleeing the third Reich and needed protection, and we lost that opportunity to help them. When you look at the experience of Jewish immigrants and refugees around the time of World War II, around the 1930s, 1940s,
但在二战期间，我们也失去了许多接纳逃离欧洲的人的机会。我们失去了这个机会，因为我们害怕，同样，我们担心国家安全。我们担心在难民中、在移民中会潜伏着会破坏美国的间谍和破坏分子。但这些恐惧阻止了我们接纳许多许多逃离第三帝国并需要保护的人，我们失去了帮助他们的机会。当你回顾二战前后（即20世纪30年代到40年代）犹太移民和难民的经历时，
paint me a picture of what happened. The popular narrative is that there are many European Jews who did make it to the United States, many of whom were involved in the scientific research that had helped the United States eventually win World War II. But was that sort of a general experience? Did the United States was the United States generally welcoming to Jewish refugees from Europe in the middle of the 20th century? No, we weren't actually. Many historians feel that our policies were highly
给我描绘一下当时发生了什么。大众的说法是，有许多欧洲犹太人确实成功来到了美国，其中许多人参与了最终帮助美国赢得二战的科学研究。但这是一种普遍的经历吗？在20世纪中期，美国对来自欧洲的犹太难民总体上是欢迎的吗？不，我们其实并不欢迎。许多历史学家认为我们的政策高度
anti-Semitic during this period. We lost many opportunities to allow Jewish refugees to come to the United States. The most classic example is the SSA in Louis. Ship carrying over 900 passengers who were fleeing Europe. And when they arrived off the American coast, the people on the ship were prevented from coming to the United States. The ship was turned away. And eventually, you know, the ship traveled to many different countries.
在这段时期内充满了反犹太主义。我们错失了许多允许犹太难民来到美国的机会。最典型的例子就是圣路易斯号。这艘船载着900多名逃离欧洲的乘客。当他们到达美国海岸附近时，船上的人被阻止进入美国。这艘船被拒之门外。最终，你知道，这艘船去了许多不同的国家。
They were also denied the opportunity to land. And eventually the ship was forced to return to Europe. And many of the people who were traveling on the SSC, Lewis eventually were caught and sent to camps, to the death camps. So when we look at the broad sweep of history here, we sort of see this pattern repeatedly occurring where groups arrive and within a few decades or a couple of generations of being here, they have concerns about newcomers entering their neighborhoods.
他们登陆的机会也被剥夺了。最终，这艘船被迫返回欧洲。许多乘坐圣路易斯号旅行的人最终被捕并被送往集中营、死亡集中营。因此，当我们纵观这段宏大的历史时，我们会发现这种模式一再发生：群体到来，在他们到达后的几十年或几代人内，他们开始对进入他们社区的新来者产生担忧。
And in some ways, we seem to have a positive view of immigration and immigrants when they were long ago and far away. But less so when they're here now, when the family that arrived last year that lives next door. And I'm wondering if you have insight into why this happens? Why is it that groups that themselves may have faced challenges as immigrants? How is it that within a couple of decades or maybe a couple of generations, they are turning around and having the same concerns that were expressed about them not so long ago?
在某种程度上，当移民和移民是很久以前、很远的事情时，我们似乎对他们抱有积极的看法。但当他们现在就在这里，当去年到达并住在隔壁的家庭出现时，这种看法就不那么积极了。我想知道你是否对为什么会发生这种情况有见解？为什么作为移民本身可能面临挑战的群体，在几十年甚至几代人的时间里，会转过身来，产生不久前对他们自己表示过的同样的担忧呢？
Well that seems to be the pattern. I guess you could say that part of Americanization is to adopt the values and the perspectives of the society that surrounds you. And it also becomes a defense mechanism. It becomes a way of proving your membership in the society to adopt those values and to reflect those values out, to demonstrate that you are a member of the in-group and not the out-group. You recently wrote an essay about the current debates over immigration, in which you said, generations from now, students in U.S. history classes, many of them, the children of immigrants arriving today, will read what our political candidates, editorialists, bloggers, and talking heads had to say about their ancestors, and shudder. What did you mean by that?
嗯，这似乎就是规律。我想你可以说，美国化的一部分就是采纳围绕着你的社会的价值观和视角。这也成了一种防御机制。它成为证明你融入这个社会的一种方式，去采纳这些价值观并将其反射出去，以证明你是内群体的一员而不是外群体的一员。你最近写了一篇关于当前移民辩论的文章，其中你提到，几代人之后，美国历史课上的学生——其中许多人是今天到达的移民的子女——会阅读我们的政治候选人、社论作家、博主和名嘴对他们的祖先所说的话，并感到不寒而栗。你这话是什么意思？
When I teach courses in immigration history and we read the editorials and the newspaper articles and the newspaper articles and the broadsides that were published in the 19th and in the early 20th century. My students often shake their heads and wonder how Americans could have ever had those feelings or their thoughts or perspectives, they laugh nervously. But then when we compare those editorials and newspaper articles and broadsides to some of the editorials and blogs and newspaper articles today, they see the continuities. And so I suspect that 20 years from now, 30 years from now, I suspect that my students reading the thoughts, the articles of today, will also find them ridiculous, will also shudder, will also wonder why Americans felt the way they did.
当我教授移民史课程时，我们会阅读19世纪和20世纪初出版的社论、报纸文章和传单。我的学生经常摇头，想知道美国人怎么会有那些感觉、想法或视角，他们会紧张地笑。但随后我们将这些社论、报纸文章和传单与今天的一些社论、博客和报纸文章进行比较时，他们看到了延续性。因此我怀疑，从现在起20年、30年后，我的学生阅读今天的思想和文章时，也会觉得它们荒谬，也会感到不寒而栗，也会纳闷为什么美国人会有那样的感受。
But I hope not. There's this part of me that hopes that we will do better, that we will be better. That was historian Maria Christina Garcia. She's a professor of American studies at Cornell University. Hidden Brain is produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman, Raina Cohen, René Clair and Path Shah. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle.
但我希望不会。我内心深处有一部分希望我们能做得更好，成为更好的人。这是历史学家玛丽亚·克里斯蒂娜·加西亚。她是康奈尔大学美国研究教授。“隐藏的大脑”由珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼、雷娜·科恩、勒内·克莱尔和帕思·沙制作。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。
This week our unsung hero is Stuart Harding. Stuart's one of NPR's lawyers, he does many things for us, from working late on a Friday to draft the rules for a t-shirt giveaway to writing the contracts for actors who will appear in an upcoming episode of the show. Thank you Stuart for all that you do for us and all that you do for everyone at NPR. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本周我们的无名英雄是斯图尔特·哈丁。斯图尔特是NPR的律师之一，他为我们做了很多事情，从周五工作到很晚起草T恤赠品的规则，到为将出现在节目即将播出剧集中的演员撰写合同。谢谢你，斯图尔特，感谢你为我们所做的一切，以及你为NPR的每个人所做的一切。我是尚卡尔·维丹图姆，这里是NPR。本集节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。